James Chapman
James: My feeling is that China is being well
managed and the government have provided necessary
stimuluses to promote growth within China.
And so, Ithink China will pull out all right.
With regard to the world generally, it seems
to me that the Chinese, one way or the other,
earn a great deal of assets which are denominated
in U.S. dollars and they will want to protect
the value of those assets and so they will
probably not sell them. And so, therefore,
the Chinese government and China generally
speaking will not make the recession worse
and I don't think that the growth in China
will have a great deal of direct impact on
pulling the West, essentially the West, out
of the recession. I think the West will pull
itself out of the recession. I've got great
confidence in that. But, so that's my view,
my overall view on this question. I'm a frequent
visitor to China and I know that China will
survive very well and will continue to prosper,
though I'm not quite sure that that will have
a direct impact on the general recession in
the West. So, that's my answer.